[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
bienvenue dans ça vous regarde en direct
voici le sommaire notre grand témoin ce
soir est une femme engagée à gauche
après la politique elle a été la
ministre de l'éducation de françois
hollande elle a choisi l'humanitaire
directrice france de l' ong one
elle revient dans le débat public avec
un livre la société des vulnérables
leçon féministe d'une crise cette crise
c'est évidemment celle du co vide
najat vallaud belkacem est avec nous ce
soir on s'arrêtera aussi sur la question
sensible des mineurs isolés étrangers le
débat est relancé après l' attaque
terroriste devant les anciens locaux de
charlie hebdo vendredi dernier à paris
l'auteur des faits n'a pas 18 mai 25 ans
comment éviter que de faux mineurs trême
la place de vrais mineurs face à face à
suivre sur ce plateau mais on commence
tout de suite avec notre grand débat il
concerne le bien-être animal comme en
quelques années la cause des animaux est
devenu une cause politique majeur
pétition référendum proposition de loi
la société civile a fini par faire
bouger le gouvernement
on en parle dans un instant avec nos
invités
[Musique]
fini donc les fauves dans les cirques et
les élevages de visons pour les
fourrures barbara pompili a fait toute
une série d'annoncés ce matin sur le
bien-être animal sujets plus politiques
que jamais en cette rentrée
parlementaire on va en parler avec vous
le donnons breuval bonsoir bonsoir merci
d'être là vous êtes député la république
en marge des alpes maritimes en pointe
sur ces questions du bien-être animal
vous avez signé le référendum
d'initiative partagée pour le bien-être
animal
on en parlera bonsoir raphaël shedden
berger jeu merci d'être avec nous vous
êtes député les républicains du haut
rhin dans quelques minutes la directrice
du cio le vf france ong qui fait la
promotion de l'élevage durable ça existe
nous rejoindra et bonsoir najat vallaud
belkacem bonsoir je suis ravi de vous
accueillir sur le plateau de ça vous
regarde évidemment vous êtes ancien
ministre de l'éducation mais aussi du
droit des femmes et de la jeunesse
vous publiez la société des vulnérables
c'est dans la collection coup de poing
la collection tract de gallimard c'est
une analyse sur les leçons féministes de
la crise sanitaire
on va en parler un peu plus tard dans
l'émission mais je suis sûr que vous
avez des choses intéressantes à nous
dire sur le bien-être animal en tous les
cas votre regard nous intéresse et je
salue enfin stéphane stéphane baert
parce qu'il vous force à lui de même si
j'ai bien compris les boues qui
commençait comme tous les soirs c'est
parti
[Musique]
si j'ai bien compris ce soir stéphane à
vous venez de le dire mais pas de mérite
à l'avoir compris si j'ai bien compris
les français sont de plus en plus
sensible au bien être des animaux alors
forcément quand vous êtes un homme ou
une femme politique et que voulait être
élu ces cas sur ce plateau
ben c'est très important de montrer que
vous êtes un ami des animaux donc si je
peux vous donner un conseil aux autres
élus peux me permettre éventuellement
c'est ne pas hésiter à poser sur les
réseaux sociaux avec un petit chat ou
avec un gentil chien pour cultiver votre
popularité
c'est pas un peu le degré zéro de la
politique posé avec ce moment là vous
êtes en train de traiter de débile mais
en fait c'est pas moi qui ai eu l'idée
c'est gérald darmanin
donc attention quand même à ce que vous
dites c'est lui qui donne ce conseil il
a donné un conseil des ministres
ses collègues du gouvernement c'était
marqué dans le canard enchaîné je vous
laisse lire l'article il dealait dégâts
pour les municipales si vous voulez
cultiver notre particularité c'est pas
des mesures techniques qu'il faut faire
c'est des photos de chiens et chats et à
que ça vous montrez que vous avez du
coeur alors est ce qu il a été suivi son
conseil
évidemment darmana c'est le génie
politique de ce gouvernement donc les
gars font un festival c'est pas toujours
probants c'est ça le problème en garde
bruno le maire lui ce débat bonne idée
lui faire ce qu'il a dit donc il a posé
avec jacqueline vous vous connaissez
jacky non c'est son chien jacky bah non
c'est pas son chien jacky jacky fétiche
de son coach au bain de regarder il a
posté la photo de jacques cousteau
cochons d'inde sur instagram bruno le
maire alors on voit pas la photo de
jacky pourtant il est vraiment très très
mignon voilà ben figurez vous qu'il a
fait quand même cinq mille juin alors
que caen bordeaux le maire annonce la
fin du confinement 2000 vue donc son
cochon d'inde est plus populaire que son
ministre voyez cesser ce cas ne pas
négligeable mais le vrai pro la danse et
bien sûr darmanin qui non seulement
poste régulièrement des photos de son
chat mais il s'est même engagé plus pour
la cause des animaux par exemple en
défendant ben la spa en l'écoutent avec
le coton vous invite ce dimanche salle
baratte au noël des animaux pour la spa
il faut venir adopter les animaux en
tout cas très vrai elle fait rien je
n'ai jamais vu mais je m'en lasse pas
mais non non ne pouvais pas parce que
d'en lancer un élu de terrain c'est
quelqu'un qui est proche de ce que
savait enfin que réclame des électeurs
aux municipales il avait carrément une
ligne pro animaux il a promis des
crédits pour rénover la spa il a promis
de créer un cimetière pour les animaux
dans sa cabine à tourcoing mais c'est
pas nouveau ça fait longtemps qu'ils
caressent les animaux nos sens des poils
en 2018 par exemple il avait déjà
interdit à tourcoing les cirques avec
des animaux sauvages donc deux ans avant
les annonces de barbara compte voilà
deux ans d'abord barabara public comme
quoi il est balancé darmana du flair
ripert que le gouvernement quand on
demande aux français qu'est ce qu'ils
veulent ce qu'ils pensent à l'action de
macron 78% des français disent
maintenant on n'en fait pas assez pour
protéger les animaux donc barbara
pompili à proposer des mesures pour les
animaux sauvages aujourd'hui alors
quelles sont ces mesures
à bord trois principales mesures
premièrement interdiction progressive
donc des animaux sauvages dans les
cirques voyez des tigres tout ça sera
pas plus possible bientôt
interdiction aussi des delphinariums
avec les orques et les dauphins et bien
interdiction des élevages de visons mais
tout ça sur plusieurs années mais vous
noterez que ces trois mesures qui sont
dans ce référendum d'initiative partagée
proposée par hugo
man et xavier niel mais dans ce
référendum il ya beaucoup d'autres
choses notamment il ya l'interdiction de
la chasse à courre
ça coince parce que forcément défendre
les animaux s'en prenant aux éleveurs de
visons ça c'est quoi encore c'est facile
il n'y a pas tant des éleveurs de visons
en france en revanche interdire la
chasse à courre s'est fâché des
chasseurs alors est ce que le président
macron va se fâcher avec ses grands amis
les chasseurs ça paraît pas évident mais
comme il ya 80% des français qui sont
contre la chasse à courre
on voit pas comment ma qu'on pourrait
éternellement défendre les chasseurs
tient sur la chasse à courre look
dombreval pour rebondir tout de suite
sur le billet de stéphane mercier avoue
stéphane vous croyez qu'un jour votre
président notre président emmanuel
macron amis des chasseurs irait jusque
là
j'en ai trop fin à cette tradition jeu
j'en rêve
je suis moi même opposé à ces chasses
dites traditionnelles et quand on dit ça
on met forcément attaquer tout de suite
en étant en disant qu'on est contre la
chasse bave personnellement je suis pas
contre la chasse j'ai jamais chasser je
serai jamais je suis pas contre l'âge je
suis contre les chasse qui sont des
chasse cruelle la chasse à courre est
une chasse cruelle la chasse à la glu
temps dell à la matole la vénerie
souterraine toutes ces chasses sont
cruels et je suis pour les abolir
effectivement raphaël chez les bergers
est d'abord je vous salut merci d'être
là je le disais léopoldine charbonneau
mme la directrice du cio bleus vf france
est une ong qui fait la promotion de
l'élevage durable vous allez nous dire
ce que vous pensez des annonces de
barbara pilée dans un dans un instant
mais je termine le tour de table il faut
aller plus loin que ces annonces c'est
déjà trop loin je crois que sur ce sujet
là c'est un sujet qui est passionné
passionnant pour les français dans
lequel on est tout de suite dans
l'émotion parce que on se laisse tous
attendrir par par un animal et c'est
bien normal
pour autant je crois qu'il faut il faut
savoir prendre des mesures progressives
avec avec raison parfois avec distance
et les cassettes progressif intégrer les
lions à son provence le temps de façon
générale comme quand on légifère ne pas
légiférer dans l'émotion et légiférer
en ayant bien conscience de ce que sa
pléthore de faire ces annonces le
contraire mais on est on est sujet j'ai
pas dit ça j'ai absolument pas dit ça je
pense qu'on est sur un sujet qui
nécessite que le politique se saisisse
de la question parce que on a bien vu
quand le politique se détache de trop
des préoccupations de ses concitoyens on
le voit les phénomène d'abstention et
c'est aujourd'hui la société nous dit
occupez vous de cette question de la
condition animale
eh bien je crois qu'il faut qu'on s'en
saisisse je ne suis pas sûr pour ma part
par exemple que le référendum
d'initiative populaire soit partagé par
don soit soit l'outil le plus en
adéquation pour cette question là qui
est une question complexe et on ne peut
pas trancher une question aussi complexe
que la condition animale par une simple
réponse oui ou non mais par contre le
signal de nous élu en responsabilité de
voir nous occuper de ceux de ce sujet il
est fort et on doit s'en saisir
najat vallaud belkacem c'est pas vos
dossiers de prédilection certes mais
c'est vrai qu'on se dit voilà des sujets
sans la société civile sans les
associations sans les ong le politique
ne serait pas au rendez vous on a
vraiment l'impression que le
gouvernement que les autorités publiques
les pouvoirs plus de cours après une
demande sociale très très forte
comment vous comprenez cela comment vous
analysé cette demande là le bien-être
animal
d'abord vous vous dites c'est pas
forcément votre sujet de prédilection en
réalité c'est absolument ce dont on
parle dans la société des vulnérables
convient donc de publier avec sandra
laugier parce que cette vulnérabilité
c'est en anthropologie de la
vulnérabilité qu'on a tenté de faire
dans ces quelques pages
elle concerne aussi bien l'être humain
nous tout nous tous c'est à dire notre
dépendance les uns aux autres que
l'environnement qui nous entoure
le caire la société du care l'éthique du
care qu'on appelle de nos voeux c'est à
dire faire attention à prendre soin
d'eux pour nous ça porte aussi bien sur
l'être humain que sur notre
environnement sur la nature sur l'animal
est donc bien sûr que cette réflexion-là
conduit évidemment à faire très
attention au bien être un loyer un
mouvement alors à ce qu'une et luc table
je crois qu'il y à ce mouvement est
cassée santé absolue mélange de naître
je pense que il y à ce mouvement dans la
société qui est celui finalement
la génération climat qui voilà qui
défilent les vendredis enfin quand on
pouvait encore le fer pour protester
contre l'inaction de vent de changement
climatique et qui s'émeut tout autant et
à juste raison du sort infligé aux
animaux mais je voudrais juste dire un
mot là-dessus parce que je trouve que
quand même cette réflexion est
intéressante
en même temps il me semble parfois qu'on
est dans une société où fort
heureusement on s'intéresse de plus en
plus aux conditions de fin de vie par
exemple des animaux mais on a de plus en
plus de mal aussi à parler des
conditions de fin de vie des êtres
humains comme si un tabou énorme peser
sur sur les humains alors je dis pas ça
pour les opposer les uns aux autres mais
je dis juste qu'il ya ce deuxième tabou
qu'il faudrait quand même levé dans
notre société et on l'a vu pendant le
confinement et la crise du de lakovic 19
quand on a eu quand même en ehpad en
particulier des fins de vie terribles
qui ont été peu à compagne et où là pour
le coup on a eu une négligence y compris
des pouvoirs publics ça ça devrait aussi
nous poser question alors on va y
revenir
tout à l'heure léopoldine charbonneau
que pensez vous de ces annonces
aujourd'hui mais je crois qu'il faut les
saluer effectivement sur ces sujets là
où les ong on tenté de faire bouger les
choses depuis longtemps et que ça ne
bougeait pas il ya eu des fausses idées
des tentatives dans le passé qui n'ont
pas abouti donc on n'est pas seulement
dans le symbole c'est pas cosmétiques un
simplement ces histoires de zinfos
cirque les dauphins delphinarium c'est
très important
c'est sûr tension s'est montrée la place
que la cause animale a en france c'est
faire écho à ça c'est important pour ces
animaux là et pour voilà montré que la
cause animale est un sujet qui est enfin
entendu parler politique et on voit que
c'est souvent est intéressant de ce que
vous disiez avec les politiques qui doit
se saisir beaucoup plus du sujet de la
cause animale et particulièrement les
sujets sur lequel séidou bluff
travaillent sur les sujets d'élevage
très clairement il ya il ya beaucoup de
travail à faire locke dombreval il ya
aussi une dimension très politique à ces
annonces aujourd'hui il ya une
proposition de loi du groupe
eds écologie démocratie solidarité avec
d'anciens marcheurs qui ont quitté la
majorité à laquelle vous appartenez
il ya cette volonté aussi de pas céder
un pouce de terrain à des causes qui
pourraient être portées par
par l'opposition les sujets qui ont été
évoqués ce matin par barbara pompidou
sont des sujets qui seront traités par
le gouvernement depuis longtemps depuis
au moins un an et demi puisque françois
de rugy en avril 2010 9 avait lancé un
groupe de travail sur ces sujets que
j'étais d'ailleurs le parlementaire qui
était en charge de cette question auprès
de françois de rugy et des conclusions
denrées dû être rendu en juillet 2010 9
circuits au vison et le dernier sujet
qui concerne celui qu'on a eu tout à
l'heure les dauphins et delphinarium il
ya eu un échange de changements de
ministres d arbitrage avait été préparé
ils ont été rendues récemment par
matignon donc c'est un sujet dont on se
préoccupe depuis longtemps
probablement que l'apparition de cette
ppl hop à rodez proposition de loi
accélérer les choses ne s'est pas
accélérer les choses mais ce que je
voudrais dire c'est que mes fins eds a
dans la même journée
cette proposition de loi des
propositions doit absolument essentiel
qui concerne le vote à 16 ans qui
concerne l'ouverture des droits à
l'avortement qui concerne le parrainage
pour des réfugiés dont une ppl qui
concerne le bien être animal
je pense même sincèrement que ma
conviction c'est de dire que on peut pas
traiter ce sujet comme ça avec quatre
articles qui réclame ray des débats
extrêmement long et non celle du côté de
ce gouvernement et de la majorité et
pourtant je suis tout de suite vous
montrer un sujet vous qui avez signé ce
fameux référendum d'initiative partagée
je rappelle qu'il faut 20 % un des
parlementaires pour pouvoir le
déclencher soit 185 députés et sénateurs
et bien au sein de votre propre camp
vous êtes en minorité des divisions qui
traversent en marche sur la cause
animale c'est signé clément perdre
le député loïc dombreval s'est donné une
mission convaincre ses collègues
parlementaires de signer le référendum
d'initiative partagée pour les animaux
pour ce la première méthode un classique
le mail collectif dams et messieurs les
députés sénateurs et sénatrices pour
celles et ceux d'entre nous sensible à
condition animale il est réjouissant de
voir combien le sujet prend de l'ampleur
au sein des sphères médiatiques et
politiques
c'est le sens de l'histoire et pour
toutes ces raisons je vous invite à
signer sereinement le référendum pour
les animaux le texte a besoin de 185
signatures de députés ou sénateurs
malgré les efforts du député le compteur
reste bloqué depuis plusieurs semaines
autour de 140
alors pour maintenir la pression il
prend régulièrement son téléphone
il appelle ici son collègue laurent
garcia signataires du texte il est
malmené par les chasseurs de sa
circonscription en meurthe et moselle
louis-laurent bonjour c'est loïc
dombreval tu vas bien ils ont uriné
horribles sur la vie sociale sur la
vitrine est en permanence d'accord mais
ils ont mais ils n'ont rien cassé quand
même du goudron de norvège et des et des
plumes de canard sont à permanence
d'accord ok tu résiste bien et est à la
signature reste sur leur sur le
référendum
ouais ouais
sur les routes de picardie ces deux
députés marcheurs vont à contre sens de
loïc dombreval s'ils s'intéressent eux
aussi au référendum pour les animaux
c'est pour lui faire la peau
alain péréa et xavier battu sont
respectivement président et
vice-président du groupe d'études
parlementaire chasse et territoires ce
jour là ils ont rendez vous sur vos
jours sur le président avec les
chasseurs de la baie de somme
cette loi qui est déposé cette
proposition de loi déposée n'est pas là
pour régler le vrai problème de la
condition animale
il est là pour faire du buzz pour
reprendre la main sur les hugot clément
et compagnie donc c'est de la politique
politicienne
à mon sens de bas étage qui ne fait pas
avancer le dossier pour faire échouer le
référendum il faut se montrer
stratégiques alors les députés
n'hésitent pas à donner aux chasseurs
quelques conseils en communication il y
a une grande partie je crois de la
population de la population qui se pose
un certain nombre de questions et donc
c'est à nous collectivement
de leur répondre si on y va trop les
agrafes à les agresser je le disais tout
à l'heure c'est ce que vient de dire
vous aviez on va perdre le match il faut
montrer que la chasse c'est quelque
chose de moderne c'est pas quelque chose
d'assez be et je suis intimement je suis
intimement convaincu que y compris chez
les urbains
on ne peut faire passer des messages et
on peut gagner on peut gagner des matchs
match il ya effectivement sur ce sujet
entre les 2 172 députés de la république
en marche pour leurs 60 d'entre eux ont
signé le référendum pour les animaux
vous êtes à l'aise dans ce groupe
majoritaire sur ces sujets là parce
qu'on a l'impression que voilà vous êtes
un peu seul oui mais je suis peut-être
effectivement un petit peu seul mais il
n'empêche que moi je vois encore une
fois ce matin des mesures qui sont
prises barbara bach pardon qui dit
pardon des mesures qui vont être prises
par julien de normandie prochainement
des mesures qui ont été prises par
frédéric vidal sur l'image
d'expérimentation et en fait je suis
apparemment pas seul puisque le
gouvernement jour après jour semaine
après semaine prend des dispositions
pour anvers facilité génial normandie
c'est le mini de l'agriculture là on va
rentrer dans le dur et c'est peut-être
pour ça sur ces questions d'élevage et
notamment élevages en batterie élevage
intensif que ça coince en fait vous
allez nous dire sur quoi il est prêt à
bouger je vais vous montrer une d'une
vidéo parce que c'est avec les vidéos
notamment celle de l214 que la société
bouge on aurait pu en prendre beaucoup
d'autres ici ce sont des cas marc
élevage de canards pour la production de
foie gras
vous voyez en fait ce sont des cages
petit avec beaucoup de saletés couvert
de défections je vous laisse regarder 15
cm de death crémant de cadavres sans
compter la présence de d'insectes doha
et c'est ce genre de vidéo à chaque fois
sacré beaucoup d'émotion dans l'opinion
mais à chaque fois les agriculteurs vous
disons peut pas faire autrement
comment qu'est ce que vous répondez aux
bosses du chameau charbonneau l'élevage
intensif
qu'est ce qu'on fait si on doit le
remplacer sans mettre en péril
l'agriculture alors moi je crois qu'il
faut accompagner le changement
actuellement en france on a plus de 80%
des animaux qui sont en élevage intensif
donc d'un côté on a les pratiques très
vertueuse à 20 pour quatre ans des
animaux ou alors énorme
voilà c'est principalement des cochons
des lapins des volailles qui sont en
élevage intensif donc c'est intensif
pour virer j'entraîne voit la cage donc
contention maximale dans les haies est
maintenue en cage donc c'est pour les
truies les cochons les truies les lapins
les cailles les poules pondeuses
donc c'est vraiment la contention
maximale après vous avez aussi en
bâtiment souvent sans accent lumière
extérieure ou par exemple vous avez la
plupart des poulets en cas d
alternatives il ya évidemment des
alternatives
il faut les encourager elle existe des
alternatives en revanche effectivement
il faut pouvoir encourager la sortie est
ce qu'on voit dans le gouvernement
actuel qui avait donné quelques espoirs
avec les états généraux de
l'alimentation où on voyait le président
macron à mi-chemin les états généraux
dire voilà c'est pas normal qui est ce
que 0,5 pour cent d'élevage bio en
france pour le pour le port c'est pas
normal qu'ils aient encore des oeufs de
poules en cage il faut vraiment faire
évoluer il faut accompagner
il faut rémunérer les pratiques
vertueuses et ne plus subventionner les
pratiques intensifs
la droite elle et elle est prête à
accompagner ce mouvement il ya de la
grille bashing aujourd'hui dans le pays
il ya ces vidéos qui qui font
qu'aujourd'hui à des français qui
veulent même plus manger de viande
donc qu'est ce que vous dites à droite
pour accompagner cette question là moi
je dis qu'un débat comme celui là ça
doit pas être un débat dans lequel on
cherche à opposer les uns aux autres
je suis complètement d'accord pour dire
que des images comme celles-là elles
sont intolérables et que ça c'est ça
c'est c'est de la responsabilité pénale
de galles après rien à plein d'idées
mais quand on les bat on montre quand on
montre une vidéo comme ça derrière et
ensuite qu'on débat de l'élevage
intensif on porte aussi à imaginer que
l'élevage intensif c'est forcément ça ce
n'est pas ce n'est pas ça non plus je
crois aussi qu'il faut savoir dire que
la large large large majorité des
agriculteurs des éleveurs
ce sont des gens qui sont respectueux
des animaux qu'ils élèvent ensuite qu'on
puisse considérer qu'il faille améliorer
avancé
respecter davantage la condition animale
oui mais il faut le faire dans des
termes responsable raisonnable en
respectant celles et ceux qui le font
sur le terrain parce que sans eux on n'y
arrivera pas et si on braque
c'est ce qu'on aime le débat sur la
chasse il est il est de ce point de vue
là intéressant se dire que qu'on ait un
débat apaisé sur des questions de chasse
traditionnelle c'est pas moi qui qui
monteraient au créneau pour m'y opposer
et je sais que dans ma famille politique
on peut ne pas tous être d'accord là
dessus
mais quand il est comme ça en porte
pendant je finis comme ça on porte un
débat sur la chasse en général moi qui
étais maire d'une commune
je vous dire que les premiers qui venait
demander à ce que les plans tirs soit
augmenté à ce qu'on sorte plus de gibier
c'étaient les protecteurs de
l'environnement c'était le nfc terre les
personnes l'abrogation du oui a
accompagné une transition ou faire ça de
façon concertée avec tous les
agriculteurs mais ce qu'on peut
concrètement à nourrir la population
française sans l'élevage intensif c'est
possible ou pas oui de la [__] est
évidemment bien motel de l'élevage
intensif c'est c'est un modèle où on met
on fait pousser des végétaux pour
nourrir des animaux et on en ressort
moins de calories donc de fait c'est un
modèle qu'on a mis en avant puisque à
une époque on disait c'est la seule
façon de sortir une grande quantité de
nourriture ou sortir la deuxième guerre
mondiale quand on avait eu faim
maintenant où il repose sur des
économies d'échelle et sur le fait à
productivité extrêmes sans respect du
bien-être animal
on peut bien évidemment faire autrement
on peut avoir plus de qualité d
l'élevage extensif est lié avec de la
meilleure qualité de des produits issus
de l'élevage bien évidemment et elle
peut réduire nos consommations et est ce
qu'on peut faire ça au même coup c'est
un peu la question aussi parce que ça
coûte plus cher j'imagine cette
transition legs dans provale et ont pu
passer imaginer le fait que apporter
moment où on n'a plus besoin de
bâtiments où on a besoin de moins de
bâtiments qu'on a des valeurs de là
du kilo de viande vendue qui sont
supérieurs parce que de meilleure
qualité ou un respect des marges des
élus des éleveurs ont plus a fait
supposer qu effectivement il peut y
avoir une amélioration du revenu de
l'éleveur et en même temps une
diminution d'intentions d'intensité de
l'élevage
moi je suis absolument je mange de la
viande gipa antispécistes je vais pour
le bien-être animal arrêté l'élevage en
batterie en cage et ne pas naître dégâts
mais bien sûr il ya il ya même des
élevages de cochons comme moi je visite
en bretagne qui ont ce qu'ils font des
pas de grand pas en avant pour donner
l'accès à l'extérieur aux animaux pour
un accès la lumière pour en faire toute
une série de d'attention qu'ils sont
portés il ya aussi du jusqu'au boutisme
danseuse bien sûr mais je mets mes jeux
mais je m'oppose à ce jusqu'au boutisme
et j'ai toujours dénoncé l'attitude
raziel s'est fixé dans ce débat mais
comme dans n'importe quel débat en
réalité sauf que il ya beaucoup
d'émotion dans ce débat et on a
peut-être tendance à écouter davantage
des gens qui sont de vrais extrémistes
du d'un côté comme de l'autre sur des
circuits comme de l'au delà pour autant
quand on a ce débat là il faut aussi
qu'on ait un débat plus général de
l'acceptabilité des conséquences de cela
je suis d'accord améliorant la qualité
et vous le dites améliorer la qualité ça
veut dire augmenter le prix va prendre
des mesures mais je dis qu'il faut alors
pleine conscience y compris en matière
d'accès à ces assez bien on peut le
gouvernement s'il a la volonté politique
de le faire
il peut faciliter cette transition et à
la pac il ya le plan de relance la
france si elle voulait elle pourrait
soutenir la transition préparent à
manger des ong vous y croyez à ce
gouvernement voulait fait confiance il
reste un peu moins de 2 ans de 2 fait
surréaliste vous le notez à combien vaut
choisir d'amener ma note mais en tout
cas il ya eu des annonces des ong
il ya du il ya eu des annonces qui ont
été faites qui donnait espoir et en
pratique sur les animaux d'élevage
il ya quasi rien il ya des mesures
pansements il ya des améliorations à la
marge mais il ya aucune volonté de
changer changer le système vers un
élevage plus durable plus qui sera qui
sera à même de nourrir une population
sur le
terme et je pense qu'il faut l'ennemi de
l'élevage c'est l'élevage intensif
le concurrent principal de l'élevage
extensif c'est l'élevage intensif faut
pas se tromper de deux coupables quelque
part on est on est en pleine mutation
voilà comme dans beaucoup d'autres
sujets on va parler de votre livre najat
vallaud belkacem dans un instant vous
vous croyez qu'elle peut se faire sans
heurts sans accidenté sur le bord de la
route et je pense évidemment à
l'agriculture cette pollution
demain si je peux me permettre je vous
félicite parce que c'est rare d'entendre
un débat apaisé sur le sujet c'était
extrêmement agréable donc je me suis
permise d'écouté moi mon avis sur le
sujet c'est que alors je rejoins
beaucoup ce qu'a dit léopoldine
naturellement c'est à dire que en fait
je pense que souvent sur ces questions
de développement durable
on en vient malheureusement a pointé du
doigt la responsabilité individuelle
alors non pas que le consommateur le
citoyen que nous sommes ne puisse rien
faire pour rendre notre développement
plus durable bien sûr éteindre la
lumière enfin oui il ya des choses qui
sont de notre ressort
recycler et c est que nous devons faire
et il faut nous apprendre à le faire
bien sûr mais par contre quand il s'agit
d'arrêter de rouler au diesel
alors qu'en fait on est dans une
situation n'a pas le choix parce qu'on
doit bien prendre sa voiture pour aller
travailler
quand il s'agit en effet pour des
éleveurs d'arrêter de procéder ainsi
alors que tout le modèle économique
autour d'eux les pousse à cela moi ma
conclusion c'est qu'il revient aux
pouvoirs publics d'agir et que c'est pas
de la vulnérabilité individuelle et donc
c'est aux pouvoirs publics en effet
c'est ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure
de moins subventionnés tel type de
pratique puisqu'elle est problématique
et je suis bien d'accord que l'élevage
intensif et problématiques donc il faut
passer à une autre pack par exemple mais
ce à un moment donné disons-nous
franchement qui a ce qui relève du
citoyen est ce qui relève des pouvoirs
pouvoirs publics le partage des rôles
merci beaucoup d'être venu sur le gâteau
des cpd débattre de ces de ces sujets
vous restez avec nous najat vallaud
belkacem pascalou lire on se pose la
question avez-vous véritablement quitté
l'arène politique
on parle de cette société des
vulnérables dans un instant
[Musique]
la société des vulnérables leçon
féministe d'une crise c'est dans cette
petite collection qui est apparue
collection qui n'est pas éphémère 1 qui
continue mais qui est apparu pendant la
crise du coc vide vous signez ce tract
avec la philosophe sandra laugier
c'est une analyse donc quelque part
assez glaçant de du partage des rôles du
partage des tâches j'ai envie de dire
entre entre les hommes et les femmes
pendant cette crise aux hommes
les choix stratégiques l' expertise la
guerre contre le virus et aux femmes le
soin le lien l'hôpital la maison les
ehpad les supermarchés on va les
entendre ces femmes parce qu'on les a
beaucoup suivi dans différentes
reportages pendant pendant cette crise
sanitaire
je vous donne la parole juste après
c'est un sujet de mario becker elles
sont infirmières aides à domicile
caissières elles ont continué de
travailler pendant le confinement en
première ligne face aux coronavirus la
france a re découvert ces travailleuses
de l'ombre des femmes mal payés souvent
peut considérer mais essentielle pour la
vie quotidienne parce que sinon comment
faire
ça va quand on voit des gens qui qui
prennent des risques qui travaillent là
et c'est d'être avec eux des assistés
les aînés boulot d'une caissière cette
chanson parce que face à la quête est
jamais vraiment comment valoriser en
temps normal
90 % des personnels de caisse sont des
femmes 90% des infirmiers des aides
soignantes sont des femmes la proportion
est encore plus importante dans les
métiers du soin et de l'aide à domicile
elles ont fait tenir la société face au
fléau du coronavirus et au sein des
foyers se sont encore elle qui assure
elle l'essentiel de la charge familiale
elle cumule télétravail devoirs et elles
ont parfois dû renoncer à leur activité
professionnelle
yolande zaoui est sur tous les fronts
je peux et dénoncer je peux pas les
aider parce qu'ils sont au collège
donc c'était difficile comment les
coachs et comment voir s'ils ont fait
des voix l'épidémie a bien plus impacté
les femmes céline aide qui le dit elle
l'institut national d'études
démographiques estime que le confinement
et la crise aurait accentué les
inégalités entre les femmes et les
hommes voilà c'est tout le paradoxe que
vous montrer très bien dans ce livre les
femmes ont tenu la société tiennent la
société et plus encore pendant cette
crise et en même temps leur place leur
droit tout a régressé pendant cette
crise comment vous expliquer au fond ce
paradoxe là cette prise de conscience
qu'elles sont utiles indispensable et en
même temps elles ont tous les progrès on
a le sentiment qu'ils ont ils ont
diminué parce que la situation reste
inchangée sur un point c'est qui dit les
choses qui fait le récit qui dit les
priorités politiques et en fait ça n'a
pas bougé d'un iota c'est à dire que ça
continue à être essentiellement des
hommes qui disent les choses
et c'est pour ça qu'on fait le lien avec
sandra laugier qui est philosophe et
avec laquelle on a décidé d'écrire ce
texte un peu fiévreux c'est vrai on fait
le lien entre la quasi absence des
femmes
sur les médias dans le leadership de la
crise et c est finalement cette absence
dans le type de décision qui est prise
et le type de gestion de la crise qui
est une type de gestion très guerroyant
très guerrier d'ailleurs on parle de
guerre
là où il aurait fallu parler de tout
autre chose face à une crise comme celle
là une pandémie on n'avait pas d'
ennemis de l'extérieur il aurait fallu
responsabiliser les citoyens il aurait
fallu parler d'attention aux autres de
soins de ciel des images d'ailleurs qui
sont très fortes
au delà des reportages qu'on a vu ce
sont ces images du conseil de défense
on va en voir une ses conseils de
défense sanitaire qui ont se sont tenues
pendant toute la crise regarder très
très très peu de femmes principalement
des hommes on les a compté quatre femmes
pour treize hommes et ce sont ces hommes
qui tous les jours ont pris des
décisions fondamentales sur notre vie
quotidienne
bien sûr donc en fait la voix des femmes
ne s'est pas fait entendre et si vous
voulez nous on entre dans cette
réflexion par la situation spécifique
des femmes qui nous saute aux yeux bon
évidemment on est féministe évidemment
on est sensible à ces questions là mais
enfin même pour des gens pas sensible à
ces questions là qui a pu ne pas
constater que les femmes dont vous
rappeliez qu'elles étaient 90 % dans
bien de ces métiers qui étaient les
premiers de corvée en fait on les a
quasiment plus entendu par la suite et y
compris dans la recherche et le nombre
de soumissions d'articles de recherche à
du côté des femmes drastiquement d un
conseil scientifique aussi sadique dans
l' expertise qu on entendait sur les
plateaux télé et c'est donc évidemment
tout le monde a vu ça nous on n'y a été
particulièrement sensible
on est entré par cette entrée là des
femmes mais en fait derrière ce qu'on
dit c'est que c'est un problème
démocratique parce que il ya les femmes
puis il ya aussi tous les invisibles
qu'on n'entend pas qu'ils seront
permanence à la périphérie de nos
décisions politiques et qui n'ont pas
plus été associés là alors on évoque par
exemple la situation des quartiers
populaires beaucoup montré du doigt
beaucoup stigmatiser les radars
d'inégalités cette crise absolument
alors que là bas aussi on a vu se
déployer au contraire une forme de
d'éthique du caire dans le sens du soin
de la tension dans le sens où les
habitants de ces quartiers populaires
ont énormément fait pour rendre service
les uns aux autres pour
ouvrir des bureaux des d'alimentaire
parce qu'il y avait des files devant la
ddt alimentaires qui ne cessait de
s'accroître et c'était accepter a montré
aussi dans le livre que certes ces
femmes si on rassure les femmes sont
invisibles ont été très vulnérable aussi
vous parler de la montée des violences
conjugales
la difficulté pour les familles
monoparentales les femmes seules ventre
le télétravail les devoirs etc et en
même temps elles n'ont pas été associés
à la réflexion sur le fameux monde
d'après absolument on les a applaudis
mais on les a aussi oublié
absolument en fait ce qui est terrible
c'est que si encore on se disait ben
c'est juste qu'elles ont été invisibles
pendant la gestion de cette crise mais
non quand on creuse très rapidement se
rend compte que non seulement elles ont
été invisibles mais en plus leur
situation s'est considérablement
dégradée et ça c'est à l'échelle
nationale vous évoquez par exemple
l'étude de l'ined qui montre que y
compris des femmes qu'on pourrait penser
protéger parce qu'elle pouvait se mettre
en télétravail et n'hésitez pas dans les
métiers les plus exposées à l'extérieur
etc
les femmes en télétravail ont subi cette
crise parce que la charge domestique
parental etc
les revenus essentiellement sur leurs
épaules elle d'armes de destructions
d'emplois ou si en termes de howard on
emploiera effet et alors si on regarde à
l'échelle du monde je me suis un peu
forcé à faire ce travail là parce que en
fait vous vous rendez compte que partout
dans le monde les femmes ont connu une
régression de leurs droits en effet et
dans les pays les plus éloignés
malheureusement de l'équilibré et de
l'égalité femmes hommes
ça a été une multiplication des
violences vous évoquez les violences
conjugales qu'on a vu d'ailleurs partout
on aime on estime à peu près 30 millions
de cas de violence conjugale
supplémentaires les six mois de
confinement qui se sont déroulés donc
bon les violences conjugales mais aussi
les violences culturelle dans un certain
nombre de pays les mariages forcés les
grossesses précoces et c'est ce qui vous
fait nous rappeler cette phrase de
simone de beauvoir qui est assez
glaçante
il suffira d'une crise politique
économique ou religieuse écrivait-elle
pour que les droits des femmes soient
remises en question cette régression là
elle est durable à votre avis mais en
fait le problème c'est qu'il faut qu'on
comprenne qu'elle risque
se produire à chaque crise on va en
connaître d'autres des crises je veux
pas vous paraître pessimiste mais la
crise écologique dont on parlait tout à
l'heure c'est évidemment une crise qui
affecte d'ailleurs elle aussi déjà les
femmes et d'abord les femmes
et pourtant ce sont les femmes qu'on
entend le moins sur ce sujet ce sont
pourtant ces femmes qui sont eux qui
apportent des réponses à la crise
écologique mais et dont on entend
rarement parler on préfère souvent
évoqué la nature sauvage la biodiversité
je trouve ça très important mais on
parle très rarement du fait de la
difficulté pour ces femmes d'aller
chercher l'eau quand y'en a plus d
combustible polluant qu'elle utilise
dans leur cuisine etc etc
donc moi je ce que je dis là et c'est
notre conclusion est que sandra c'est
que en fait à partir de maintenant que
cette crise du coc vide nous serve à
quelque chose
à partir de maintenant il faut
considérer que tant que les femmes ne
sont pas réellement présentes dans
l'univers politique dans l'univers de l'
expertise dans l'univers médiatique
et bien en fait leur voix est oublié et
donc leur sort est oublié et donc à
chaque fois qu'on n'aura pas cette
présence eux à la hauteur qu'il faut il
faut partir du principe que leur
situation continuerait à se dégrader et
si l entrée en force progressivement
dans toute une série de secteurs
décisive de l'action sociale publique
est ce que cette société du care que
vous appelez de vos voeux alors il faut
expliquer un petit peu le caire où c'est
vrai se mettre en oeuvre c'est à dire le
lien le soin
mais kim est qui et qui n'est pas
dévaloriser c'est-à-dire faire en sorte
que prendre soin de l'autre et des plus
vulnérables devienne une valeur en soi
oui alors d'abord pourquoi est ce qu'on
parle de care est paré pour qu'on
n'existe pas un mot français parce qu'en
fait il n'existe pas en français désolé
de mots qui disent pas simplement le
soin au sens de soigner un patient mais
aussi l'attention à l'autre le souci de
en fait le contraire de care en anglais
c'est clair la snes qu'on peut traduire
en français par la négligence
donc en fait ce qu'on appelle de nos
voeux c'est une société dans laquelle
ont certes on cesse de négliger de
négliger toute une série de missions
dont pourtant notre société a besoin
pour vivre celle qui assure la
continuité de notre vie sociale en effet
s'occuper des enfants prendre soin des
personnes âgées
voilà c'est essentiel ça fait c'est pas
des choses à reléguer à des personnes
qu'on sous payent ou à la femme du
ménage ça c'est la première chose mais
aussi cesser de négliger des gens des
individus des gens qu'on rejette à la
périphérie des gens dont on n'écoute pas
la voit donc le politiques n'écoutent
pas la voix ne prend pas en
considération des priorités c'est aussi
ça contre quoi une eti l'heure du caire
veulent lutter quand on vous écoute
najat vallaud belkacem cette éthique du
quai on se dit que vous avez une vision
et quand on a une vision fencing qu'on a
envie forcément de la faire partager et
de la et de la construire
ça vous manque pas la politique
franchement mais à vrai dire j'ai pas
l'impression d'avoir cessé de faire de
la politique c'est intéressant ce
malentendu qui a parfois quand on me
pose cette question puisque je pense que
je suis comme des j'espère des millions
de français sans doute plus qui ont un
avis qui sont engagés qu'ils souhaitent
voir le monde où la société changé et
qu'ils le font pas forcément à travers
un mandat électif jeu suffrages c'est
fini ce nom murmure que peut-être les
régionales puisque c'est la prochaine
échéance à ce que
mais je pense qu'on était à laurent
wauquiez en rhône alpes mais quelque
chose auquel vous pensez
parce que quand on a des convictions et
j'en ai des très fortes quand on a des
convictions il est naturel d'avoir
vocation un jour à exercer des
responsabilités a tenté de le faire tout
du moins puisque ça passe par un vote
donc non ce n'est pas fini bien en fait
mal gêné les régionales à lyon bien
entendu nous verrons la réflexion est en
cours
moi je ce que je crois pour ces
élections régionales c'est qu'elles sont
essentielles vraiment essentiel est
essentielle pour les territoires en
question évidemment essentiel aussi pour
ce que ça dit de la capacité notamment
de cette formation de gauche à laquelle
j'appartiens au sens large de porter un
projet crédible auprès des français pour
dans un an
aussi donc je pense que c'est très
important un an et pour dans un peu plus
un peu moins de deux ans pour 2022 est
ce que vous avez vous avez forcément vu
cette une de libération je suis sûr que
vous l'avez vu une femme pour sauver la
gauche on va l'avoir 7,7 une il y a
christiane taubira nidal go clémentine
autain delphine batho
manon aubry il vous l'ont oublié je n'ai
pas de mandat électif vous venez de le
rappeler pour 2022 pour sauver la gauche
najat vallaud belkacem
en fait cette couverture m'a mis mal à
l'aise pour être franche pour quelle
raison je crois que c'est la formulation
une femme je pense que en réalité il y
en a de multiples c'est bien ce qu'on
voit là et que s'il faut aller chercher
une femme c'est pas au nom du fait que
c'est une femme au nom du fait qu'elle
serait l'exception qui confirme la règle
il faut aller la chercher je pense que
le journal a voulu bien faire qu'il a
voulu d'une certaine façon s'inscrire
dans un monde où justement on ne regarde
pas ces questions de genre et on
reconnaît la compétence des uns et des
autres simplement une femme présidente
en france quand même ça serait une bonne
nouvelle mais il faut aller plus loin je
pense que en fait la couverture idéale
aurait été une couverture qui mêlait des
hommes et des femmes à gauche et laisser
le choix en effet aux militants et aux
sympathisants et avec votre photographie
ou pas qui peut écrire l'avenir
honnêtement à ce stade moi ce que je
crois c'est que on se relève pas encore
d'une crise qui a été difficile qui sera
très douloureuse sur un plan économique
parce que c'est aussi de cela que l'on
parle dans ce livre est que nous devons
repenser nos modes nos modus vivendi
démocratique
je pense vraiment que la démocratie est
en souffrance aujourd'hui je pense que
la gestion de crise a montré un état en
réalité très faible équipe lui il était
faible et plus il tenait un discours
autoritaire et que c'est pas comme ça
qu'on qu'on s'adresse à des citoyens à
un moment où de six grands défis et en
particulier de changement climatique
nous attendent sur lesquels il va
falloir qu'on embarque tout le monde
s'est dit je voudrais vous faire réagir
pour terminer à ce débat ce débat si je
vous la corde n'est absolument pas
nouveau il revient ces jours ci à
l'assemblée nationale faute ils abaisser
l'âge du vote à 16 ans alors c'est une
petite enquête qui a mené à thomas des
prêts dans sa chronique aujourd'hui
puisque cette proposition de loi revient
à l'assemblée nationale ce rappel voter
thomas oui ou non vous exactement myriam
c'est un sujet qui revient souvent ici à
l'assemblée et qui a beaucoup fait
réagir les députés je vous raconte tout
ça alors c'est ce qu'on appelle un
serpent de mer en politique un sujet qui
revient depuis des décennies faut-il
accorder le droit de vote à 16 ans
notamment pour endiguer à la faible
participation chez les jeunes c'est en
tout cas la proposition que font les
députés du groupe écologie démocratie
solidarité
mais pourquoi cette fois ci il y croit
la proposition sera débattue cette
semaine à l'assemblée
nous on a rencontré la coprésidente du
groupe c'est elle qui a déposé la
proposition de loi et sept députés c'est
vous bonjour par la forte n'a le droit
de vote à saison un sujet qui revient
tous les ans tous les deux ans pourquoi
cette fois ci ce serait le bon moment
parce que on voit aujourd'hui on dit
beaucoup que la jeunesse et dépolitisée
c'est pas du tout vrai on les voit de
plus en plus mobilisés dans la rue sur
les réseaux sociaux sur des combats qui
leur sont propres
l'environnement le féminine
mais les vêtements au lycée il nous met
face à nos responsabilités et donc il
faut leur faire confiance
il faut les écouter il faut envoyer un
message mais est ce que quand on a 16
ans on est suffisamment mûre pour
pouvoir voter choisir le président de la
république par exemple
alors ça c'est déjà une idée qu'il faut
combattre c'est à dire que le vote n'est
pas l'expression d'une capacité il n'y a
pas de personnes plus intelligente que
les autres ma grand-mère le vote de ma
grand mère a le même exactement la même
valeur que le vote d'un jeune de 16 ans
que le vôtre que le mien le vote c'est
l'expression d'une volonté d'une
légitimité d'un droit et pas d'une
capacité d'une intelligence et c'est
alors le président de la république
s'est déjà exprimé sur ce sujet il avait
été interrogé par le youtube heures hugo
traverse était en 2019 écouter ou au
contre le droit de vote à 16 ans est ce
que vous êtes favorable suis pas opposé
mais je peux pas m'empêcher de vous
renvoyer la balle
on peut pas dire on a les trois quarts
des jeunes entre 18 et 25 ans qu'ils
sont pas allés voter ya cinq ans et me
dire mettez la majorité à 16 ans
le président n'est donc pas complètement
content mais pour le moment le sujet est
entre les mains des députés qu'en pense
qu'il vous allez voir ils sont plutôt
divisées sur la question
c'est en quand même on est capable on
doit pouvoir voter donc pour moi c'est
une bonne idée
oui moi il me semble que c'est une idée
intéressante si on veut que les jeunes
puissent davantage participer à notre
vie politique
j'suis pas sûr qu'en abaissant de 18 à
16 ans on améliore les niveaux
d'abstention chez eux
s'il n'y a que le droit de vote à 16 ans
alors c'est du sparadrap
c'est de la com c'est du bluff quand on
regarde après les autres pays
en europe on est tous quand même câble
et sur cet âge là à 18 ans c'est bien
que derrière il y avait une raison qui
était valable pour les 11-18 ans sur
giscard de vie aujourd'hui valable pour
les gens de 16 ans voilà je pense que ça
mériterait une réflexion et c'est un
sujet que je trouve être un beau sujet
de réflexion pour les élections
présidentielles si vous aviez dû voter
vous à 16 ans vous auriez voté pour
crier à l'époque j'aurais voté à droite
je sais fameux première à 16 ans il
était engagé dans le mouvement des
jeunesses socialistes à 16 ans qui
arrive en année ils auraient voté pour
tous jacques chirac
je pense qu'à saison jour j'aurais voté
communiste
j'avais 4 16 ans donc j'étais en 86
serait voté pour mi temps voilà meriam
donc le droit de vote à 16 ans on n'y
est pas encore la proposition sera
débattue en commission jeudi
puis dans l'hémicycle ça sera le 8
octobre alors c'était évidemment à
l'ancien ministre de la jeunesse que je
vais m'adresser
bonne ou mauvaise idée le vote à 16 ans
bonne idée non mais moi je soutiens
absolument je pense que enfin vraiment
il faut être des phases et totalement
déphasée pour ne pas voir ce qui se
passe dans notre société les jeunes de
cet âge là ont un engagement qui est
absolument inédit c'est la génération
climat qu'on évoquait tout à l'eau qui
sont capables de décider
en fait pour l'instant ils ont une forme
d'engagement qui se traduit par de
l'activisme pétitionnaires
manifestations etc et il nous faut nous
les adultes les convaincre que c'est par
la politique que ça passe en vérité nous
on sait que c'est par la politique que
ça passe deux ans n'ont pas forcément
encore conscience la bonne façon de le
faire c'est notamment de leur permettre
avec leur énergie et transformatrices
qu'ils ont à cet âge là précisément
entre 16 et 18 ans puisque après on
commence déjà s'installer un peu il faut
leur permettre à l'état une voie pour le
22 ans
on va aborder pour terminer un sujet qui
cristallise souvent émotions et parfois
idéologie il faut bien le dire les
mineurs isolés étrangers à nouveau à la
une après l'attentât de vendredi dernier
tout de suite ses face à face
[Musique]
un face à face qui oppose ce soir hélène
soucieuse david bonsoir vous êtes
porte-parole de france terre d'asile et
face à vous thibault base un bon soir
soit elle vous êtes député les
républicains de meurthe-et-moselle
membre du groupe d'études sur des
mineurs isolés étrangers avant de vous
donner la parole les clés pour
comprendre ces complexes ses succès
signé à medtech on les appelle les
mineurs isolés étrangers de jeunes
migrants qui arrivent en france 100 par
an combien sont ils
ils sont en fait de plus en plus
nombreux à être prise en charge par les
conseils départementaux
selon un rapport parlementaire en 2016
ils étaient plus de 8000 et selon les
derniers chiffes en 2019
il était un peu plus de 16000 il arrive
du maghreb tout proche de nombreux pays
d'afrique noire mais aussi d'afghanistan
du pakistan des immigrés qui affirme
être mineurs à leur arrivée
comment vérifier qu'ils ont bien moins
de 18 ans les départements ou les
associations désignées par eux comme la
croix rouge à paris ont pour mission de
vérifier l'âge de ces jeunes étrangers
une évaluation faite sur la base des
déclarations du demandeur de ses papiers
d'identité s'il en a et d'un
questionnaire sur son parcours de vie
selon un rapport parlementaire plus de
la moitié des demandeurs ne sont pas
reconnus mineurs à l'issue de cette
évaluation le département peut également
demander un examen d'âge physiologique
le fameux examen osseux problème peu de
mineurs et de médecins acceptent de plus
loties paraît obsolète et présenterait
une incertitude de 18 mois dans le
résultat
si leurs minorités valider les mineurs
sont ensuite remis aux mains de l'aide
sociale à l'enfance et après leurs 18
ans que deviennent ils
les chanceux intègre un contrat de
jeunes majeurs qui permet
l'accompagnement social jusqu'au 21 ans
les autres bascule dans le droit commun
des étrangers plus dead sociale c'était
le cas de l'assaillant présumé
pakistanais
alors justement parlons de ce cas précis
ce jeune pakistanais qui est passé à
l'acte vendredi dernier et qui a
manifestement menti sur son âge thibault
bazin votre famille politique depuis
quelques jours elle explique que s'il
avait été vérifié s'il n'était pas passé
entre les mailles du filet pour le dire
simplement si on avait su qu'il était
majeur et non pas mineur quand il est
arrivé sur le sol français
eh bien on n'en serait pas là est-ce que
qu'est ce que vous partagez ça ou c'est
pas un peu simpliste il ya un problème
des mineurs non accompagnés qui dans
leur nombre en crû de manière
exponentielle puisque on était à quatre
mille en 2010 l'association des
départements de france et évoque le
chiffre de 40 mille aujourd'hui avec des
conséquences financières humaines pour
les services de l'aide sociale à
l'enfance que vous connaissez bien mais
ça les met en tension dans l'eure dans
leur quotidien et on a un problème sur
cette phase d'évaluation de la minorité
qui aujourd'hui relève des conseils
départementaux mais ils n'en n'ont pas
les moyens
c'est difficile c'est coûteux c'est des
procédures extrêmement complexe et vous
passez le cas d'espèce je vous entends
tu devrais être à droite dire en gros il
ya une grande hypocrisie sur les mineurs
étrangers isolés
celui là il a menti oui parce que lacan
vouloir trouver et il est passé à l'acte
quand vous retrouvez face à un mineur
qu'il n'était pas 18 ans et en fait il
en a 25
on voit bien que 25 ans c'est quand même
pas rien on aurait fait un test
radiologique osseux comme c'est possible
on aurait pu démontrer qu'il ne l'était
pas auquel cas on aurait pu j'allais
dire mener toutes les procédures pour le
renvoyer dans son pays
alors qu'est ce que vous en pensez pour
france terre d'asile on arrive tout de
suite à cette question du test osseux
c'est à dire que pour bien comprendre ce
sont les départements qui évalue l'âge
de ce jeune quand ils arrivent sur le
territoire
qu'est ce qui se passe en général
comment ça fonctionne concrètement ils
vont nous dire et si c'est si ces tests
osseux sont efficaces alors déjà je
voudrais juste revenir sur ce chiffre de
40 mille qu'on entend partout c'est un
chiffre qui n'est pas vraiment étayée
par une statistique officielle on trouve
que l'assemblée des départements de
france le ministère de la justice dont
dépendent les mineurs isolés étrangers a
recensé moins de dix sept mille mineurs
l'année dernière enregistré et c'est
même en baisse par rapport à l'année
dernière donc on n'est pas dans une
croissance exponentielle c'est une
goutte d'eau par rapport au nombre de
mineurs qui sont enregistrés à l'aide
sociale à l'enfance qui est de 320
milles donc pour vous il n'ya pas du
tout de laxisme de certains départements
qui donnerait trop facilement des géants
des milices
des chiffres très petit sur les haies
sur l'évaluation de l'âge c'est une
procédure complexe qui des termes qui
débouche toujours sur une décision
judiciaire donc c'est pas seulement à
l'appréciation d'une association ou d'un
département alors au départ si c'est le
département qui évalue n'ont donc la
première étape
voilà c'est de la responsabilité des
départements qui peuvent soit faire une
évaluation dite sociale c'est un
entretien avec beaucoup de dinde
éléments qui sont prises en compte et en
suisse que gimd documents qu'on présente
il ya les justifier et à la peau d'un 10
pour essayer d'évaluer lundi s'il ya une
évaluation des documents qui sont
données avec une vérification de la
fraude documentaire potentiel et enfin
il est possible de faire des tests d'âge
de osseux c'était celui-là c'est le juge
c'est le juge sont à la demande du juge
et c'est est-ce qu'ils sont présentés
comme la panacée où la réponse magique
il faut savoir qu'elles sont basées qui
sont basés sur un référentiel des années
1930 sur une population dite caucasienne
et que le minimum de d'erreurs
est de dix huit 18 mois à deux ans
sachant que la majorité des jeunes qui
arrivent chez nous ils ont entre 15 et
18 ans et donc donc c'est totalement
inefficace les tests autres étaient
inscrits sur les chiffres moi je on a
auditionné l'asean l'association des
départements de france
quand le directeur général nous évoque
des chiffres ces chiffres sérieux
d'ailleurs constate dans les
départements on a eu une multiplication
du nombre
je prends dans mes en meurthe-et-moselle
c'est pas moi qui le dit le président
socialiste évoqué une multiplication par
4 entre 2015 et 2017 c'est des chiffres
à la rogerie furent les points d'accord
l'évaluation de l'âge sur l'évaluation
de l'âge
il ya plusieurs éléments notamment en
2019 a été bien il ya eu un décret qui
prévoit que les conseils départementaux
peuvent amener les jeunes à la
préfecture et qui a eu la constitution
d'un fichier biométrique
or on a trois départements encore qui
sont récalcitrants à ce dispositif
et c'est pas normal paris la
seine-saint-denis et la meurthe et
moselle et on le voit bien quand on est
déboutée dans un département
on doit pas pouvoir aller dans un autre
en fait comme on nous dit c'est qu'il ya
certains départements laxiste d'autres
qui sont moins laxiste et plus le
département est laxiste plus la filière
est intéressé et on voit bien
aujourd'hui pour faire passer un mineur
ça coûte à peu près à la famille aux
amis dans les territoires d'origine
jusqu'à 15000 euros alors que pour un
adulte c'est 7 millions au coeur est un
problème selon vous sur l'évaluation par
le département sur les tests au seul
jour et que l'état s'en occupe il
faudrait que l'état qui en occupe vous
le feriez datant du 9 heures rick dean
alors de façon à ce que ce soit une
seule et même institution administrative
qui évalue l'âge des mineurs quand ils
arrivent et qu'il demande
cette protection ce statut qui protège
l'état peut piloter peut aider
financièrement la protection de
l'enfance reste
une système particulier qui dépend des
départements donc nous on est ce sont
des enfants avant d'être démis grande et
donc c'est important que ça reste
fréquence des départs de ses finances et
jeunes quand ils sont qualifiés
si je peux dire de mineurs isolés vont
ensuite être prise en charge par l'aide
sociale à l'enfance ils vont être
scolarisés ils vont être hébergés pour
bien comprendre
on voit bien qu'ils sont pas tous
mineurs c'est d'ailleurs le cas que vous
preniez en introduction qui a 25 ans il
y en a pas 18 et donc en réalité on voit
bien quand on discute un peu avec les
services jusqu'à trois quarts des
demandeurs qui viennent pour bénéficier
du dispositif qui et qui fait l'honneur
de la france accueillir des mineurs on
n'accompagne pas un mineur comme un
majeur et c'est très bien qu'on
accueille les mineurs dignement
d'ailleurs il faut qu'on ait les
conditions aussi et que l'état assume
financièrement cette prise en charge
parce qu'aujourd'hui ça coûte 2
milliards et l'état n'en assument car la
moitié que vous n'êtes pas d'accord sur
en gros celui qui doit évaluer premier
ressort entre les départements pour
l'enfance ou sur la méthode l'état mais
sur les tests il n'y a pas vraiment de
recette magique pour être sûr de l'âge
d'un jeune quand ils arrivent de deux
ans de de marge d'erreur est énorme
quand vous discutez avec les radiologues
on peut peut-être faire évoluer les
référentiels mais très clairement ils
ont un certain nombre d' indices qui
établissent très clairement si les
mineurs ou pas après on peut en débattre
longtemps sur les tests radiologiques ni
au ce mais en vue ce qu'on vient de
vivre
vu cet appel d'air qui est créé et puis
quand même imaginer 4000 il ya dix ans
quarante mille aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui le message qui est passé et
c'est envoyer des jeunes en disant
qu'ils sont mineurs et quand ils auront
18 ans on aura en des facilités pour
pouvoir obtenir une carte de séjour
or nous il faut qu'on puisse bien
accueillir les vrais mineurs qu'on doit
protéger la marque
les onglets accueil vous avez vu la une
du parisien aujourd'hui au fond le vrai
sujet c'est pas justement ces réseaux on
le voit la goutte d'or dans le 18e
arrondissement
derrière qui instrumentalisent des
jeunes qui deviennent délinquants qui
sont toxicomanes qu'on rémunère
et là je parle de réseaux notamment au
maghreb par des médicaments qui sont des
drogues
est-ce que c'est pas ça le vrai sujet
c'est l'hymne à la juste pour terminer
sur ce référentiel c'est pas moi ou
france terre d'asile qui dit qu'il ne
marche pas l'académie de médecine dit
qu' il ne va vous revenez sur les tests
aux fouilles sur les tests de ces
compris qui n'est pas et sur
effectivement on est quand même sur des
populations extrêmement vulnérables on
parle à grande majorité des personnes
reconnues mineurs d'adolescents enfin
vous voyez ce que c'est un adolescent
sans leurs parents sans attache ses des
personnes qui ont un parcours migratoire
difficile souvent avec des traumatismes
qu'ils ont connaissez non vous
reconnaissez qu'il y à un réseau où il y
avait des réseaux jeunes mineurs isolés
violence qui prévaut dans la délinquance
c'est le reportage de ce matin dans le
parisien mais il ya là des réseaux qui
vont profiter de cette vulnérabilité de
l'isolément de ces jeunes donc la
réponse c'est pas de dire on va faire
des tests plus conclure est difficile
plus strictes et mettre encore plus de
jeunes à la rue c'est au contraire de
les aider les prendre en charge de les
accompagner
et c'est pas en déclarant des plus de
mineurs majeur que l'on va mettre fin à
des problèmes de délinquance ou ce qui
s'est passé sujet extrêmement sensible
voudrait arbitrer ce débat à les y est
les dix points mais j'aimerais le décès
le mot de la manade renaud lagrave deux
contre un mais c'est très important ce
sujet là parce que il n'ya pas que les
tests se ya fichier biométrique un sound
éléments il ya une question de moyens
aussi pour pouvoir prendre en charge ces
éléments mais les trafics d'êtres
humains on ne peut que les luttes et
enfin julien moi je j'attends de vous
aussi si on veut faire vivre le droit
d'asile qui est l'honneur de notre pays
on doit aussi lutter contre ceux qui se
font de l'argent là dessus et extraire
d'êtres humains il faut absolument les
combattre et mettre un arsenal dissuasif
à la gloire d'un dispositif plutôt
incitatif mais je vous allez vous
retrouver là dessus un mot ce sujet il
va forcément voilà m
dans la campagne présidentielle on
entend déjà les voies politiques s'est
élevée dans les deux camps on peut avoir
un débat apaisé sur les mineurs issus
étrangers en fait ce qui est frappant et
vous êtes vous-même observatrice du
débat politique depuis quelques années
et vous le savez c'est à quel point
c'est un marronnier qui revient
extrêmement régulièrement est posée à
chaque fois de la même façon avec un
manque d'imagination
cruel les tests osseux on en a déjà
parlé vous en souvenez par ailleurs il y
avait déjà les mêmes réserves en effet
de l'académie de médecine le manque de
fiabilité etc
mais on leur met quand même sur le tapis
en fait moi ce qui me frappe c'est con
il me semble qu'on se pose pas la bonne
question le sujet c'est pas tant est-ce
que tel jeune homme en question à 16 ans
ou à 19 ans que à partir du moment où il
a été accueilli en france
comment est-ce qu'on a intégré comme ans
qu'on la protège et y compris de lui
même et comment la protéger des réseaux
parce que c'est vrai que ces réseaux
existent et c'est vrai qu'il nous faut
lutter contre et c'est en ça que je
refuse de laisser dire que la gauche ne
serait pas attaché à la notion de
sécurité moi je suis attaché à rouvrir
ce débat à l'arrêter je pense qu'il faut
lutter très fermement contre les réseaux
de traite des êtres humains et que ces
jeunes gens sont des victimes de ces
réseaux d eau
merci merci le temps presse il est
presque 20h30
l'heure pour moi de rendre l'antenne
merci beaucoup si la jad vallaud
belkacem d'être venu sur ce plateau et
vous être prêter à ce jeu du commentaire
sur différents sujets je rappelle le
titre de votre livre avec la philosophe
sandra laugier la société des
vulnérables leçon féministe d'une crise
merci à tous les deux et à demain
[Musique]